>> Hi, I'm Cay.
>> I'm Sara.
>> We'll be the instructors for this course. The way most people interact with
their computer is in the same way that I just did with my Word Processor. There
were a lot of buttons, but if there isn't a button for what I want to do then
I'm stuck.
>> However, there's a secret language that you can use to make your computer do
whatever you want it to do.
>> In this course, we teach you that secret language. When you learn it, you will
have power over your computer.
>> We'll get you started with the Java programming environment, and you'll write
your first programs.
>> You might make a few mistakes. That's okay. Actually, it's good, because you
learn from your mistakes.
>> We're really excited to teach you the secret language, so that you can make the
computer do what you want it to do. Let's get started.